[Music]
there'll be no prefacing of this
all i'm gonna do is say and now
bubble board jousting ready ready
and
joust
my whole life
since i was a wee lad to be nothing
but a night
the worst irish accent
you'll do what i say ladder i feel the
back of my hand speaker are you going to
compete in the chest
[Music]
no i don't want to hurt myself ren's
been a real thorn in my side with that
mechanical keyboard
every time i try to concentrate what do
i hear it's tap and tap tap tap tap
but i got a way to get it back i got a
mechanical keyboard of my own
[Music]
what's your favorite food
huh
what's your favorite food hot dog
that you can't see anything in the
helmet
at all
what are you doing i'm helping no you're
not that's not helping
at all here that's that's how you're
supposed to wear it it's a monday
mondays kind of suck but that doesn't
mean we can't try something we've been
meaning to do for a long time for your
viewing pleasure
bubble board jousting
hello i'm bandanna guy i have the favor
of the joust that these fine knights
will fight for we can now begin the
games
his majesty is here
waiting for bluetooth connecting
[Music]
ready
sir rosen chuck the unbalanced will win
jess
[Music]
my lord isn't known for being the most
balanced person
but he's got this in the bag
i'm kind of curious as to what's going
to happen if they
let's go head-on into each other you
want to be super cool keep the side of
your eyes and also tell people you watch
a slightly obscure techie vfx youtube
channel well today's your lucky day we
have a coradoa digital hat right here in
uh katakana japanese katakana it says
the name of corridor so it's pretty neat
it's a limited edition hat the thing is
we can only make as many hats as we have
orders for wait for the orders to come
in they make all the hats specifically
for you guys and off they go so friday
may 26th is the last day of the limited
edition sale so hop on over to our store
corridor digital.com store hey do you
guys notice by the way we no longer have
the dash in our url now you can just go
to corridordigital.com that's pretty
cool
anyways check them out limited edition
if you guys want a hat now's a great
time to check it out uh and with that
i'll leave you with this picture of ian
sam high school
if neither if neither night falls on the
first joust the the joust continues
until one falls
right if neither yeah do you want me to
say that normally jake probably has
about 20 pounds on nick how much do you
weigh nick
i weigh about
165. how much do you weigh jake
205.
nick needs to go according to my
calculations at least 15 percent faster
than jake to equal out
i believe in you sir nick sir rosen
chuck the unbalanced will win
15 faster than jake to equal out
chelsea
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i can't go on squire
you must ride for me
i'll film the shot
[Music]
[Music]
i shall avenge my
sir master
and
chess
a drop a draw
[Music]
[Music]
is that he's that smaller statue to get
under me
i think he's gonna be really good for
like workplace tensions for the rest of
the month
all right
at night you
sir squire
you did it arise arise at night squire
i'm squire the knight
now that you have avenged me i may rest
easy
my squire
my friend
my brother
[Music]
rest well sweets
oh i'm bleeding it's not like a c-mic
level
so i tried to go really fast floored on
the hoverboards you have to lean forward
so i just leaned forward too much i'm
trying to float
and i just felt myself falling the
helmet
went right into my nose
all right squier
i got it you're gonna wear that helmet
still
it's a family tradition i didn't get my
work out in this morning but guess what
all hope isn't lost because of our
patrons for you patrons out there for
you very special patrons i'm gonna do
pull-ups in your honor chris bryant
these are for you
sean witt you dog don't think i forgot
about you it hurts
two
three
four
number three celso is hero aka sohak lie
push it out
number four mr james bailey
number five richard blackburn
this one's gonna hurt
luckily your contributions will cool the
pain of all that lactic acid burn let's
go
[Music]
thanks guys
if you're interested in supporting these
videos and others like it consider
checking out our patreon
patreon.com
corridor digital
thank you guys
dude
week
3 24 in the morning it's race day if you
haven't yet check out casey's new
marathon video that went up today it's
really good it makes me want to get up
and run it's really awesome
[Music]